c'est aujourd'hui le jour du dépassement
le jour où selon les calculs d'une ong
américaine l'humanité commence à vivre à
crédit
puisqu'elle a dépensé en seulement sept
mois l'ensemble des ressources que la
terre peut normalement régénérer en une
année complète savez nous rappeler notre
manière d'utiliser la nature de nos
façons de prélever les ressources elles
sont non durables selon global footprint
network
en 1970 la terre les mains d'un
équilibre puisqu'il fallait une année
complète pour arriver à ce point de
bascule mais cette date fatidique à
reculer lentement
mois après mois jusqu'à la fin juillet
au final c'est notre surconsommation qui
à cet effet la surconsommation et des
matières premières sur consommation au
niveau de la production
on compatit beaucoup trop cette année
c'est le qatar qui est le plus mauvais
élève de la classe
alors qu'il est de lapider plus que sa
part de ressources en seulement une
quarantaine de jours à l'autre extrémité
l'indonésie avec un score très honorable
quant au canada encore une fois il
affiche une très mauvaise performance
les canadiens sont et les québécois
malgré ce qu'on veut penser on veut se
passer vers mais au final faut faire
face à la réalité
on en a beaucoup d'efforts à faire pour
devenir véritablement vers la méthode de
calcul de luigi américaine est parfois
contestée elle tient compte d'une
multitude de données permettant de
comparer l'empreinte écologique de nos
sociétés et la capacité de la nature de
se remettre du traitement choc qu'on lui
a fait subir au final malgré ses
imperfections la formule al'avantage de
capter l'attention du public
c'est un un argument de plus pour nous
montrer l'ampleur de la crise
environnementale que ce soit la crise
des changements climatiques de
l'effondrement de la biodiversité la
pollution systémique leur
surexploitation des ressources
naturelles tout ça est mélangé dans un
cocktail explosif
global footprint network n'a observé que
ce recul de la date de dépassement
depuis 1970 soit en 2020 l'année des
grands confinement ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal